all right so we're going to look at some
material today from two of these new
republican members of the u.s
house who were elected in november today
we're going to be looking at an
interview with republican congressman
madison cawthorne
and shortly we're going to look at some
tweets from republican congresswoman
lauren
bobert and here's what i really want
everyone to get from this
among uh yes how to identify and defeat
really bad arguments that's important
but there's a bigger story here
these people whose material we're going
to look at momentarily
they got elected riding the trump scam
train they didn't run on policy
they didn't run on being experts in a
particular
issue or on certain types of subject
matter they ran
on merely playing trumpian characters
riding the wave of support for trumpism
that exists to a greater degree in some
parts of the country and in some
districts in the united states
and the problem with electing what are
essentially characters
playing a political acting role is they
don't know anything about anything
there's no
substance to them whatsoever now in
general in american politics there's a
huge role
for personality you all know this
personality appearance
uh public speaking ability ability to
raise money there's a whole bunch of
stuff that in american politics on both
sides
it can get people elected who are not
the most qualified and doesn't mean
they're actually equipped to deal with
policy
in depth but this has never been more
acutely so than among this latest wave
of people who got elected merely for
being pro-trump cultists in areas
that have a lot of pro-trump cultist
voters so let's get right into this new
republican congressman madison cawthorne
has been very loudly saying first of all
that he goes armed to the house of
representatives
but also that there was likely fraud and
wrongdoing in states like georgia
arizona pennsylvania and others because
of mail-in voting and other
stuff that trump has also been repeating
you all know the stories it took two
months between the election and the
inauguration two and a half months
of them repeating these same bogus tired
stories
and cothorn actually voted against
accepting
certain states election results in the
house of representatives on january 6th
so kawthorne goes on cnn and he's
interviewed by pamela brown who came
very prepared
and is asked about the fact that his
arguments for voting not to certify
some states apply to the state in which
he was elected north carolina as well
but
he never claimed that there were
problems in his state
even though the guidelines he has a
problem with in other states
apply just as much to north carolina
this go this could not have gone any
worse for madison cothorn he's going to
have to stop doing these interviews
um but before we get to that part here's
pamela brown
challenging madison cothorn to cite
evidence of election fraud she
says and i love this you must have so
many specific
instances of of of evidence of fraud
right and he did not
what are some specific examples that
informed this
bold decision this audacious decision
even after the riots
to decertify the results you must have
seen some concrete evidence
well pam the things that i was not
objecting to the election on behalf of
was things like dominion voting machines
changing ballots or these u-haul trucks
pulling up filled with ballots for joe
biden as president
the thing i was objecting for is things
like in like i said in the state of
wisconsin particularly in the town of
madison
there was a an appointed official in
that
town who actually went against the will
of the state legislature and created
ballot drop boxes
which is basically ballot harvesting
that was happening in the parks
but this was all litigated you you know
that the trump campaign litigated all of
this more than 60 cases and they lost
either the cases were dismissed the
trump campaign withdrew or they never
brought a case
because they didn't have the evidence to
back it up
indeed i believe specifically and this
is the one that i debated on behalf of
on the house floor
in wisconsin uh that was never heard
because they
dismissed it because of standing now i
don't believe that that is a concrete
enough
well there were three trump appointments
okay so you have wisconsin but
you never you ended up not actually
voting against wisconsin it was just
arizona and pennsylvania because you
didn't have the senate votes
um but okay so he didn't object because
of machines
or massive ballot dumps coming out of
the back of trucks okay
but in wisconsin some official created
drop boxes
but as pamela brown points out that was
all litigated
it had no merit but the most important
is
he keeps talking about wisconsin he
didn't end up voting against
certification in wisconsin he voted
against certification
in other states this is so incoherent
we'd need an hour to tease it all apart
and it gets even worse three trump
appointed judge
actually throughout these cases because
of merit it was because of merit there
were three
trump appointed judges out of all of
these judges and the more than 60 cases
that were tossed out you keep talking
about wisconsin
i'm still not hearing any specific
examples of fraud if you would
just tell us what are the specific
examples you saw a fraud because
when you think of fraud you think of a
vote you're slipping one pass the
election official or a vote was stolen
somehow it didn't count did you see that
specifically
no payment like i said that's not the
reason i contested the election
so this is already just a disaster for
this guy
and then pamela brown points out the
contradiction between
kawthorne saying he has issues with the
changes to election rules in wisconsin
where his own state where he was elected
north carolina
made similar changes because of the
pandemic look at this this
if you have an aversion to cringe walk
out of the room right now
keep focusing on was focusing on
wisconsin but there were several
battleground states
that you contested to that you talked
about there were several
that president trump had lost so it's
interesting you're focusing on wisconsin
but would you apply the same issues you
had with these battleground states to
your own state
of north carolina because north carolina
also changed a lot of the rules
even after voters had started voting why
didn't you have concerns about your own
home state of north carolina
well you know pam i'm actually not aware
of the laws that were changed inside of
north carolina i believe we had a very
safe and a very secure election here
uh oh wait what north carolina was fine
safe secure
even though they did lots of the same
things
but north carolina simply didn't become
part of the narrative
and it keeps getting even worse if you
can imagine
so there's no reason to contest that
yeah there were several rules
um one of which is to extend when the
mainland ballots could arrive i
i believe by around seven days that was
one and there were a couple of others as
well
um that that were changed even after
people
started voting so i'm just wondering if
you're so
concerned about the you know these rules
being changed
with the election why why wouldn't you
focus on
your own home state of north carolina i
mean you're telling me that your concern
really
is about election integrity not politics
not the results of the election right
that is absolutely correct i didn't do
this for any one man or against any one
man
okay so north carolina though the same
issues you've had and you've expressed
about the battleground states
those are the same issues that are in
your own state of north carolina and
north carolina actually did have mail
and ballot fraud in 2018. so
so you're not concerned about your home
state and whether you were duly elected
by your own standards
well i'll tell you because of the
mail-in ballot fraud that happened in
the midterms here in 2018 i believe our
election integrity standards here in
north carolina
are some of the greatest in the country
i think they should apply this metric
all over the country but that's just my
opinion
so he doesn't know anything about it or
at least claims to but it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter his election was
definitely accurate
because he won so he definitely won fair
and square
and then later in the sort of wrap-up to
this complete
farce of an interview he admits yeah the
election wasn't fraudulent i did what i
do what i could do to push back
but it actually was not a fraudulent
election well so but then madison why
did you push back
can you now say that the election was
not stolen that it wasn't a fraudulent
election
yes i think i would say that the
election was not fraudulent um
you know i the the constitution allowed
for us to be able to push back as much
as we could and i did that to the
amount of the constitutional limits that
i had at my disposal so now i would say
that joseph r biden is our president
and you have no regrets no i do not have
any regrets
okay listen republican congressman
madison cawthorne thank you for coming
on
so either he's going to need some
serious media training
or he will have to stop doing these
interviews and this
is what happens when we elect characters
to play lawmakers on tv it's not about
governing
it's the new version of winning a
reality tv show that's all it is
and pamela brown so easily dismantles
this guy
to the point of it being humiliating for
him and you almost start to feel bad for
the kid
except that he chose to do this and
people voted him in
and now he can wield power and do a lot
of damage so
it isn't necessarily a new phenomenon
in our political history that
incompetent people get elected that's
not new
and we've seen that on both sides but
the way
in which the cult of trump has been
weaponized
to propel completely clueless people who
have no business
even being on the house floor like it's
not even about what they do
they have no business being on the house
floor their big concern is bringing guns
to the house floor
um it is particularly pernicious right
now now contrast this
if you want to think about someone who's
the opposite of people like madison
cothorn and lauren bobert who we'll talk
about
think about jamie raskin okay you don't
have to agree with everything jamie
raskin does
you can say jamie raskin is not
progressive enough or whatever jamie
raskin
is a guy who cares about policy and
depth
and brings a depth of knowledge about
the issues
and he can talk about the he is a sort
of politician's politician and he
suffered tragic loss recently
with the death of of one of his children
but he comes to mind as the antithesis
to these clueless reality show
characters let's now talk about
lauren bober if you are anything like me
you probably aren't thrilled with the
idea of going into
a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there is a
practical and affordable way to take
control of your health
and get personalized care from the
comfort of your home
it's a service called steady md they're
one of our sponsors
you take a quiz you get matched with a
licensed primary care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one-hour
video call with your new doctor you
establish a meaningful relationship with
them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor
can do perform medical evaluations talk
to you about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or co-pays i took their
quiz they matched me with a doctor
who specializes in my particular health
needs and situation the doctor they gave
me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs
they have a special offer only for my
audience you'll get 50
off your first month but only until
january 31st so make sure to sign up
soon
click the link right underneath this
video